Boris Johnson's written to every
household in the country today
effectively saying that things are going
to get worse before they get better do
you think a tighter lockdown is
inevitable well the stakes couldn't be
higher this is about saving lives and in
order to save those lives we need to
have an economic response that makes
sure that people are financially secure
in their homes and what the government's
announced so far has been very welcome
but there are a number of gaps and it's
forced many workers and many
self-employed people to choose between
their health and their financial
situation and that's not acceptable so
for example this week we know that Boris
Johnson told us that we needed to stay
in our homes and we should only leave to
get essential provisions to care for
vulnerable relatives or to go to work if
we couldn't work from home and when you
look at the government's guidance on
their website it stated that if you
can't work from home essentially you
should go to work and they've stated but
indeed it's important for business to
carry on now there are workers right
across the country this week you've been
going to construction sites where houses
call centers where their health is being
put at significant risk and the
government needs to now be very clear
about what non-essential and essential
work is and make sure that those workers
are at home if they're not providing an
essential function and that they're
financially protected so just to be
clear then are you effectively calling
for all non-essential workplaces where
work can't be done from home to be
closed down effectively certainly when
we see the pictures that we've seen this
week in warehouses in building sites
where workers are on top of each other
and we've heard reports every single MP
across the country will have had reports
about workers who are frightened because
they know that their colleagues have
gone home sick with the suspected
coronavirus we know that people's lives
are being put at significant risk and
that places further pressure on the NHS
further down the line so there's no
excuse for those employers not to
furlough those staff because the
government scheme is being made
available to provide 80 percent of their
wages but there are a number of other
deficiencies in the government's
economic response certainly in terms of
making sure
that job retention scheme applies to all
workers particularly those who have
reduced hours to make sure that their
full wage is covered there's also an
issue for the self employees now what
the government outlined earlier this
week was welcome
but many self-employed people have to
wait till June to receive a payout from
this and that's not acceptable
when we've seen other countries such as
New Zealand roll out similar schemes far
quicker so we need the government to
really really make sure that resources
are deployed into HMRC
so that those self-employed people who
are eligible can access that cash as
quickly as possible and aren't forced to
go to work there's also a gap in terms
of those self-employed people who aren't
covered by the scheme and when they're
not they're told to go and apply for
Universal Credit Rating statutory SiC
pay which is 94 pounds a week now 94
pounds a week is not enough for anybody
to live on and the government has indeed
admitted that themselves so firstly we
need to have that amount increased so
that it's enough to live on but we also
need the system that can provide the
direct cash immediately end the
five-week Universal Credit wait and
provide all around rather than alone to
those workers and self-employed people
that need to rely on that I just want to
go back to the idea of whether or not
businesses non-essential businesses
should close or not are you worried
about the balance between of course
halting the spread of the virus but also
managing to keep the economy running in
some form particularly if all the
evidence points that we may be in this
situation for many months to come the
most important thing in all of this is
protecting human life and every single
decision that's made economically has to
be centered around that now we will
recover we will need to make sure that
we have a huge investment in support
package available after this crisis is
over to really boost our economy and get
things moving again
but at this time the government's main
priority should be ensuring that people
are able to stay in their homes and that
they're financially protected in order
to do that now Jeremy Corbyn was on the
program last week and he welcomed the
money that had been pledged for
tackling the virus and he then suggested
that it vindicated what he'd done at the
last election and he said it's what I
was condemned for asking for to deal
with the scourge of poverty in Britain
three months ago so do you think that
this kind of emergency financial rescue
package shows that Jeremy Corbyn was
right all along I think the crisis is
highlighted how connected we all are to
each other and it also highlights the
fragility of all of our lives no matter
what our job is whatever our income is
we're one paycheck away from destitution
in many cases and it's also highlighted
the dramatic underfunding of our NHS and
public services to an extent that we
weren't capable of being able to deal
with the crisis such as this so going
forward if we learn anything from this
crisis when we rebuild our economy it
has to be upon foundations that provide
all of us with financial security and in
order to live on and it also provides
the funding that our public services
desperately need to deal with future
crises such as this at the same time
though and do you think it's quite
difficult to compare the arguments that
we were rehearsing in the December
election which seems like a lifetime ago
in a minute with the emergency measures
in the face of the global pandemic that
has perhaps the worst health crisis
since 1918 not at all I mean certainly
what we've always been calling for a
properly funded public services and they
weren't properly funded they're still
not unfortunately and that we would have
been in a better place to tackle this
crisis if we had listened to the advice
of medical advisors three years ago for
example when they told the government
that we needed to invest in protective
equipment advice that was ignored
unfortunately we wouldn't have been in
this position if we provided a safety
net that was capable of catching people
when they fell with it with a benefit
system that was enough for people to
live on and we wouldn't have been in
this situation if we had stronger
security for many of our workforce who
were in extremely precarious situations
such as zero our contract workers and
the self-employed now and the Labour
leadership contest of course on which
you were a contender finishes in a week
fallen away of course down the news
agenda with everything with coronavirus
and but if you win would she be prepared
to join a government of national unity
of the prime minister aren't you - well
I've already been collaborating with the
government and and urging them to listen
to my advice and the advice of my
colleagues in tackling this crisis
because we want to be as helpful as
possible we're not criticizing the
government when we're offering and our
suggestions as to how this crisis can be
better dealt with we're trying to help
and that's what I'll do as leader and
that's what I'll do if I'm not leading
I'm supporting a new leader and now just
one more question that I have to ask you
as well there's been lots of changes of
course to the way that the leadership
contest has run because of coronavirus
and is it right that you've been asked
to record a victory video just in case
and isn't that going to be a little bit
awkward I think it's trying to it's a
deal with these strange times and have
an announcement on the leadership
contest that our members and the public
can view from their homes really it's
it's logistic leaked white challenging
and I think we've all been asked to do
this victory speech so that it can be
sent out over the airwaves as quickly as
possible after we win I've done mine yet
by the way isn't your gonna feel a
little bit awkward when you record it
though before knowing the result it's
gonna be a bit bizarre yeah I can
imagine I'm Rebecca lone Bailey thank
you very much for being the program